good morning Millennials welcome back to
the
[Music]
toast
Hy Friday Friday gotta get down on
Friday everybody's looking forward to
the weekend weekend Friday Friday day
getting down on
Friday hello letter Deo happy Friday
happy [__] Friday [__] it's
exciting it's been actually I feel like
a very fair week sometimes the week
feels very long sometimes the week feels
short I feel like this week felt fair I
mean it's all subjective you know I feel
like a newborn at home so it's it's been
a very long week like I'm so if you
couldn't tell by my like like little
extra mph I put in the Friday song like
I'm Overjoyed Overjoyed for this day of
fry yeah oh my God we had a night oh my
god did we have a night like a real
newborn night every two hours so we were
told that like it's so important for
Theo to eat and we've been so like
hellbent on making sure he eats enough I
think yesterday we really overfed him MH
oh my God was he [__] in his pants every
two hours last night like my whole house
is covered in poop thank God I'm like
getting rid of pretty much all my
furniture like every rug is covered in
poop there's poop on the couch there's
poop on the bed there's poop everywhere
damn yeah it was a really hard night and
I can't even complain because Ben did so
much more than me and he's not even
complaining but I have my period so like
it made it harder and there we go
everyone you can mark that off on your
calendars and by the way it's like day
three or four of my period And I didn't
even bring it up yeah you didn't bring
it up like day one well sometimes you
have a period that like joins you on day
one and like makes itself known that's
most of the time it's like it'll rock
your world day one day one was kind of
quiet for me this this month I feel like
periods day one usually solve my
problems like oh I've been feeling
bloated and irritable and it's like
thank heavens the period has arrived
it's the days before that really get me
no for me it's like when I get my period
I'm like oh that's why I've been eating
so much that's always what it is but I'm
like always eating you know yeah but at
least once a month like you have an
excuse I have something to blame it on
yeah
so we just had a night and a half
and
tonight Ben's wonderful mother has
agreed to watch Theo for the night like
I need to sleep we have not slept like
soundly in like 11 days my eye twitch is
on fleek I know everyone who has like
actual children is rolling their eyes at
me please like I'm doing the best that I
can I need a break
like I'm not okay so Theo's staying at
his grandparents tonight and honestly I
will miss miss him dearly but like my
God am I excited are you going to go out
I'm I'm going to go to dinner like when
I civilized dinner but I would like to
be in bed by 10 o'clock
nice yeah nice um few things okay one I
started Matthew Perry's book and I just
have to say I am in love with it I'm so
glad it's amazing like if you're into
friends obviously there's so many good
like friends things but if you're just
like into Hollywood I didn't know like
before he got cast in friends he was
like really a part of like the Hollywood
scene and all these people he came up
with and how many amazing things
happened to him before friends because
we weren't really friends was aired in
1994 so this was like really before our
time
um and I do have one complaint about the
book but you can definitely tell that
the book is written by him because I
feel like if I sat down and had a
conversation with Matthew Perry I would
know the exact type of Personality I'd
be sitting down with he's very all over
the place like start a story and like
you're not sure why he said it maybe
like three chapters later he'll bring
that story back up it's a little all
over the place but it's so good yeah I
like when celebrities go out of their
way and their editors and ghost writers
too like go out of their way to make
sure the book sounds like the person
like I felt that way about Paris
Hilton's book like it very much felt
like her train of thought yeah yeah no
it's really good and there's a whole
part in there about River Phoenix I feel
like River Phoenix is like a big
Hollywood thing that was also before our
time
um but Matthew Perry before he was
famous got like a role in it was like
his first big deal role even though the
movie flopped in a movie with River
Phoenix and he was just like such an
unhappy young kid Matthew Perry like he
was an alcoholic from literally the time
he was 14 and he was just so unhappy and
he had like a not a hard family life but
he came from like a broken family and
this like couple of weeks that he spent
in Chicago with River Phoenix were like
the best of his life like when it was
over he like cried in his hotel room he
didn't want to go home and and a few
years later River Phoenix famously died
Outside The Viper Room over a um from a
drug overdose and Matthew Perry like
lived down the block and he like heard
the whole thing and he didn't know what
was going on he just like went to sleep
and when he woke up the next morning he
like found out that his friend River
Phoenix had died there's just like so
many like Hollywood moments in there but
I think the most interesting part of the
book that I thought of you
immediately is he like spends his whole
life in therapy he's very transparent
about like the amount of money he spends
and how much money he was making he
spent in total about $7 million on his
recovery and cuz it was he's been in
he's been sober slot sober for 40 years
yeah and he talks a lot about like what
he learned in therapy and like why he
was driven to drink but when he was two
months old he was a very very collicky
baby his parents couldn't [__] take
it like it was non-stop screaming so
when he was two months old they took him
to the doctor and something they did in
the 60s was they prescribed him a
narcotic barbod all pheno barbol
all and it was like the only thing that
worked so he would literally his parents
would give it to him he would literally
be stoned and finally sleep for like a
day and I think he contributes that to
his like chemical Obsession like
inability to stay away from alcohol and
narcotics to that which was something
that they did very commonly in the' 60s
100% I would say that's a fair
assessment and that's what's so crazy
like and that's the' 60s it's not even
that far off but things that were like
common common and medically done and
recommended like we're so wrong there's
so many things like that and it just
like makes you wonder today direct to me
uh labotomy labotomy labotomy yeah no
like what are we doing now that in 50
years they're going to be like I can't
believe they did that in the early 2000s
no and that it was like inhumane and
cruel I mean I can think of a few things
honestly isn't that such a I was I was
reading it my mouth was hanging wide
open that is shocking but just like add
it to the list like they used to you
know put those leeches on you to suck
the blood out of your like all
throughout history like horrible medical
ideas that were touted as revolutionary
and you're crazy if you're against this
so also another thing about the book
that I love it's kind of reminds me when
I watch the crown like the second I
finish an episode of the crown I'm
Googling 45,000 things yeah there's so
many things about mear he's not like a
neppo baby because no I guess he is so
his parent his dad like abandoned them
in Canada moved to LA he had these
dreams of being an actor and he ended up
being the Old Spice guy which at the
time was like a kind of how we would
think of like the dois guy like
everybody knew him yeah or Jake from St
farm right right but he wasn't like a
celebrity but he was like a working
actor who had this gig and he was
somewhat recognizable so it afforded
Matthew when he eventually moved to LA
like a little bit of clout and he went
to like fancy private schools his mom
I'm highlighting so many things from the
book his mom was in Canada she became
like a she became kind of famous because
she was p Pierre Trudeau's press
secretary and she was just this
beautiful woman who was kind of like
tree pain you know always photographed
next to Pierre Trudeau and she became
like a little bit of a socialite and
then she got this gig for the national
news and she became like kind of famous
and then she ended up marrying another
news anchor who ended up being the host
of day line who everyone's obsessed with
Keith marrison and they're still married
to this day but wait what was the point
oh so Matthew Perry weirdly like grew up
hanging out with Justin Trudeau because
they were like similar ages actually he
went through like a really rebellious
face he was a really unhappy kid like
starting from the age of 10 he was just
like a misery he beat up Justin Trudeau
they got into like a fight they threw
arms as friends or as foes like foe foe
so they weren't friends they were just
like around each other a lot because
their parents that's really funny no
it's an amazing book like I'm I think
it's a great book club book and then of
course I'm up to the part now where he
books friends and all of that is so
interesting it's like they
knew the the script hit the pilot scene
and there's like a star of every pilot
let it's like the show that's going to
be big I don't know if that happened so
much anymore but
like but this was real like you got a
time slot like it was all very like old
school TV Guide energy and they just
knew everyone in town was gunning for
this role and his best friend he was
best friends with this crew Hank aaria
who's that guy who does The Simpsons
voice and this other guy Craig Craig got
Chandler Matthew Perry wanted it so bad
but he was locked into this dumb role
for a sitcom that was going nowhere it
was about baggage claim handlers in the
year 2100 he was like I was so desperate
it was so stupid and he couldn't
audition for anything else and he was so
mad he was like Chandler is me I know it
I know it his best friend gets the role
but his best friend gets the role and
also gets offered something else another
role in another sitcom so he sits down
with Hank isaria and he's like guys what
should I do I got both these roles
should I take friends or should I take
this other one and they said you got to
take friends like they were really
honest with him the guy takes the other
role Hal Matthew per didn't speak for 2
years so then how did Matthew get out of
his thing um it flopped and one of the
showrunners was married to one of the
show Runners from friends and was like
hey is your [__] show going anywhere we
want Matthew Perry to read for Chandler
and they were like yeah you can have
them they just happen to be married got
it no it's so good Lisa cud wrote the
forward and it's very quick I started it
last night I'm further into it than I
was iron flame got it well I finished
iron flame I maybe I will read I have so
many things on my want to read list now
like obviously I have to read Britney's
book but then I just I think I'm going
to go in a more non-fiction Direction
I'm just not in a fiction state of mind
right now no uh wait not so you're in a
celebrity Memoir is what you're looking
for I want truth yeah yeah it's so good
I really highly recommend okay maybe
just don't be like put off by his
writing style it's very erratic but
there's good [__] in
there now another thing that happened to
me today that I wanted to talk about
that I so upset about is that the golden
Bachelor was spoiled for me wow I mean I
know that Gary is spoiler alert spoiler
alert engaged I saw that I don't know
who the woman is I do like and I don't
even engage with any sort of Bachelor or
golden Bachelor things on Tik Tok and
this morning they served me two
back-to-back videos of the winner and
him talking about their W wedding
planning right they're getting I tried
to the first time I tried to ignore it
and put her name out of my mind the
second time I saw it her name is
solidified in my mind I'm so sorry do
not ruin it for me I will not I'm so
upset maybe you'll forget you do have a
bad memory yeah but like now that I've
seen it twice and now I'm talking about
it and you're thinking about it yeah I
it's with me for for good
understood so we've got a great show
today so many stories that actually um
came across my desk in the last 24 hours
that I sent to you did you include all
three of course I did so I'm excited
about that I feel like it's kind of a
juicy day for a Friday it is kind of a
juicy Friday with a juicy
placenta
yikes you look beautiful I got some new
things for our family trip and I
couldn't wait to wear them that's how I
felt that's the thing about and I would
just experienced something similar
because one of our sponsors and a brand
that I've just now become obsessed with
and I really hadn't shopped at before is
Loft and they just sent me a huge box
and I'm like oh this is all perfect for
our trip I put it in the other room
because I literally will just I'm so oh
oh oh the out I'm wearing today was for
my first box from Loft and I'm like oh
this is perfect for our trip I've worn
it five times yeah I put the new box of
stuff in another room I when you get
stuff for a trip like how do you not
wear it before unless it's like beach
clothes but right I just want to say
like we are on camera every day like why
not wear our nice new things and if I
wear it again in 4 weeks like it'll be
okay it'll be okay but there's something
exciting about having something new and
wearing it for the first time on your
trip but it's also something exciting
about about having a nice new outfit for
your big show where's your vest from
it's from revolve so cute and my top is
revolve my pants are Lululemon and my
shoes are Ugg my shoes are Ugg and my
whole fit is Loft I love it I need to
shop more Loft stuff cuz now I need more
new stuff for the trip no guys
everyone's sleeping on Loft I know we've
been trying to tell them well honestly I
I feel them I I think with Association
asle we all think like an Taylor Loft is
where we used to get like our pants for
our internship chips like you don't
think of it as like comfy cozy cute they
had like a whole Rebrand I think and
it's really cute stuff I got like
scarves gloves matching sets really cute
stuff oh exciting yeah I need to do a
bit more shopping but I also like have
plenty of loungewear I don't need to go
crazy but I just wanted like a few nice
new things that I'm already wearing so
for the stories today tree pay has lit
the Universe on fire I cannot wait to
talk about that okay so let's get into
it okay without further ad Ado here are
the fast f stories that you need to know
and the fast five stories that you need
to know were brought to you by Sunglass
Hut it's the season of giving but
finding that perfect gift can often feel
like searching for a needle in a hay
stack I think I found the solution to
all of our gifting woses with all the
shades of holiday at Sunglass Hut where
it's about the magic of gifting
sunglasses are the best gift they're one
size fits all they are the best gift
everybody loves sunglasses also stocking
stuffer yes there's so many good brands
whatever your price range is like you
can find something and Sunglass Hut is
in my opinion the best way to shop for
sunglasses I actually just went in there
to buy sunglasses for myself and I also
bought you a pair I had the most
fabulous experience like the sales lady
Wendy was so nice and so helpful she
just knew a lot about like my face shape
my face shape has changed so I used to
go for like the biggest most oversiz but
now I'm kind of into like a cat ey and
she was helping me figure out like if
square or round frames she would the the
sales people there are just like really
smart knowled super helpful and they
just have the best Styles and the Best
Brands they have the biggest brands like
Prada Jo Chang gabana ver Rayban Oakley
Burberry their wide range of sunglasses
cover some of the hottest Brands so go
to Sunglass Hut to to discover 10 unique
Shades such as Cutting Edge Versace with
an Innovative interchangeable lens or
the Rayband Mega Hawkeye along with so
many other signature Brands talk to
their expert sales associates and try
out the latest technology both in line
online and in store so head over to
Sunglass Hut and discover the special
selection of Shades in store and on
sunglasshut.com there's the perfect gift
for everyone this holiday so head over
to your nearest store or go online to
sunglasshut.com and check out their
unique selection of Shades available
only at Sunglass Hut you're going to
love what you find so visit them in
store or online Sunglass Hut is the
destination for all your holiday gifting
needs today's episode is also brought to
you by Dipsy picture this you're hanging
out in your favorite spot headphones are
on and the world around you just Fades
away listening to One of dipsy's stories
you're going to become immersed in a
vivid world where every touch breath and
stolen glance is felt with breathtaking
intensity so I've become you know like
kind of known in my community as a smut
expert I think people come to me you
know for guidance
they do and that's why I'm really
excited about Dipsy to be working with
them because this is taking to the next
level like sometimes you with smut like
it's like we said it's a Gateway like
you start small and then you can't get
enough and Dipsy is for the experts okay
so Dipsy is an app full of hundreds of
short sexy audio stories designed by
women for women they bring scenarios to
life with immersive soundscapes
realistic characters you can discover
stories about Second Chance romances
like whatever your favorite Trope is
they have friends to lovers you know
enemies to lovers whatever your Trope is
I personally love like childhood
reconnection Dipsy has it for you
there's a growing library of fantasy
series if you're into like vampires
Greek gods fairy smut you can explore
the bounds new content is released every
week so in between listening to your
favorite stories over and over again you
can always find something new to explore
let Dipsy be your go-to place to spice
up your me time explore your fantasies
relax and unwind or even heat things up
with a partner for listeners of this
show Dipsy is offering an extended
30-day free trial when you go to dipy
stories.com toast that's 30 days of full
access for free when you go to dips e a
stories.com toast dipc stories.com
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by rakitin rakitin is the most
rewarding way to Shop and Save because
their members earn cash back on
everything that they buy rakitin is a
shopping platform that partners with
with over 3500 stores across every
category so it's Beauty clothing
Electronics Home department stores pets
Etc you are already shopping at your
favorite stores so why not save a little
more while doing it it's really a
no-brainer so for the holiday time we're
all spending so much money when we're
shopping online for gifts for ourselves
gift for others and just being a member
of rackon is just a no-brainer it's
literally the easiest thing on the
planet and you will get cash back at
over 3700 stores so wherever you shop
like Macy's Adidas Walmart Nike blooming
Dales hello Levis Urban Outfitters blue
Mercury YSL Beauty
so obvious Neiman Marcus saxs Fifth
Avenue there's literally no reason not
to become a rakitin member so it's just
a rewarding way to shop this holiday
season if you're into cash back which I
don't know who wouldn't pay rakitin has
17 million members who are already
saving and their members have earned
over 4.6 billion in cash back so get
that rakitin app for free and download
the free browser extensions you'll find
the best deals sales and coupons they do
the work for you so searching for a
coupon code you don't have to do that
anymore they will save you time they
will save you money the app is free the
browser extension is free do it download
it become a member change your life
thank you rakon thank you tury you're
welcome our first story Taylor Swift's
publicist tree Payne slams gossiper Duma
over the insane Joe alwin marriage
ceremony claim so here's what happened
Duma got a blind item about taylored
very long about Joe and nonsense the
song glitch their relationship timeline
whatever then dooa posted that with the
caption on top of it saying she did have
a ceremony in either 2020 or 2021 in the
UK and it was described to me as a
marriage by more than one person it was
never made legal I will die on this hill
put it on my Tombstone I have no reason
to lie I could give a [__] what she does
I'm sorry she didn't tell you guys about
it in a song but just because she
doesn't sing about something doesn't
mean it didn't happen so then tree Payne
who's Taylor Swift's publicist the one
and only for you guys probably recognize
her she's like that very tall beautiful
redhead who's always with Taylor she's
like a really most publicists aren't
like front-facing but Taylor everyone
knows her publicist she's popular within
the Swifty Community like she's a and
she's she's only Taylor's publicist
she's not like someone who's just the
publicist to the Stars like she's
Taylor's public Miss Americana too she's
Taylor's mouthpiece if she's saying
something like she is speaking she's the
voice of Taylor she's like a full-time
employee just for Taylor so this is
Taylor speaking through tree saying she
screenshotted this saying enough is
enough with these fabricated lies about
Taylor from dumois there was never a
marriage or ceremony of any kind this is
an insane thing to post it's time for
you to be held accountable for the pain
and Trauma you cause with posts like
these so I was shocked absolutely geod
to be reading this for a multitude of
reasons one tailor tree never responds
to anything people say the crazy like
her thing is that she never responds and
it's a good strategy because
you give air you give life to it I
wouldn't have seen that do M post if not
for tre's response so I found it even
more shocking because I feel like maybe
at one point people were reading every
word dumois said probably during Co like
when everyone was really bored they were
really taking everything jumas said as
gospel but then over the years so many
things came out to be not true so now
it's just like a fun thing that people
enjoy it's like tabloid but I don't
think and I would love for people to
sound off in the comments like when you
read something on dumo like what do you
think about it because for me at least
I'm like it's so 50/50 I I don't really
I really don't give it much Credence so
to find that Taylor Swift the biggest
star The Beatles of of Our Generation
would be bothered by and respond and
give air to something posted on J I find
so shocking because from my point of
view something being posted on Duma is
kind of meaningless these days am I
wrong I no it's it holds less weight
than it once did because a lot of things
have come out to be not true and also
just people have are not as highly
engaged with that sort of content as
they once were but she dumo like
sometimes will post something and is
like this is what people are saying take
it or leave it that's what she does most
of the time it's like she literally says
like not verified rumors but here she's
throwing her whole weight I will die on
this hill put it on my Tombstone still I
don't think it was it required a
response from tree because I think that
like tree and till are they just
Above This they're huge like but she's
never really goes that hard for a
rumor yeah but also like does her going
hard for a rumor move the needle in
terms of public perception I feel like
no I feel like when I think about blinds
like I think about entty and I feel like
I got to that place I used to like read
them every day and be like oh my gosh
and then I got to a place where it was
like I'll keep this in the back of my
mind about someone but it's not going to
color everything that I think about them
but if he like said I will die on this
hill put this on my Tombstone like this
is where I'm going to stake my claim
like this is what I know for sure if I
was like you know a oh these this shirt
has holes so cool oh I love thumb holes
Norma kamale Queen um if I was a even a
fan or a passive fan I'd be like oh okay
so that's true so let's backtrack a
little bit so I just also want to say J
has responded Yes yes yes we'll get to
that we'll get to that but let's talk
about this so a little bit of context
for someone who might not be like as
chronically online as me is that Taylor
like a few days ago released a song that
had been like a
an an exclusive what's it called like a
deluxe a bone a deluxe bonus song if you
bought her CD Now there's ripped off
versions all it all over Tik Tok if
you're a Swifty like you know it and you
might not have ever actually streamed it
but this week she actually put it on
Spotify to say thank you for making me
the number one girly and the song is
called you're losing me and it's very
clearly about Joe Owen I wouldn't marry
me either a pathological people pleaser
who only wanted you to see her it's very
much like a breakup song whatever so
nothing about that was particularly
shocking except then a day later after
the song was released in order to
promote the song Jack antinoff posted a
picture of Taylor and I think it was
from the day they wrote the song and he
shared that the song was written in
2021 so that like made the Swifty spiral
to be like wait Taylor's been unhappy in
this relationship since 2021 have they
been broken up that long so to was
posting this was on the heels of
everyone being like wait have these two
really actually not even been together
since
2021 and then she said these two were
actually married I Know It In My Bones
whatever whatever so now the question is
well she said they had a marriage
ceremony but it was never made legal the
question is what about
this Duma posting bothered Taylor so
much you want to know what I think it
could be what
I think that
maybe she if she technically like had a
ceremony where she was like married to
Joe and she never told that to Travis
and now Travis might be thinking like do
you have an ex-husband like were you
married to Joe I think I Claudia Claudia
yes and so she needs to put like
adamantly State like I was never married
before because like not that it would
make Travis like think of her any
differently but that's something that
you would disclose to a new partner so
it's like wait did she not tell me that
she was married so that's kind of a
crazy hypothesis the one that I'm
choosing to believe that I do credit to
Liz Woods she put this on her story and
it made a lot of sense is that Taylor
and Travis like are getting really
serious and like the idea that they
could be married or engaged sometime
soon isn't out of the realm of
possibility and so Jack anof posting
that like this song about the breakup
was actually written in 2021 puts a lot
more room between her two relationships
making it easier for people to digest
okay not that anyone had a something to
digest the relationship seemed far
enough apart for me but piggybacking off
of that what I thought you were going to
say is that she's taking this
relationship very seriously she wants to
perhaps marry him and she wants the
world to know like that this would be
her first and only marriage like if if
now we know she had this little marriage
with Joe like oh so this is a second
marriage like it's different as opposed
to like no I'm finally choosing to Wed
this man not any man the more you say it
it's not crazy but also totally
separately there's a new Hulu
documentary um about trail trailer and
Travis um with like Sports Experts and
pop culture experts and we are on it we
are they they reach out to us about like
sitting down they wanted us to be like
experts on the the dock we I didn't want
to do it no but they still included us
um just like clips from our podcast
because they were talking about how the
whole world is obsessed with this and
they say even the toast podcast was
talking about it and they had a little
clip of us oh my God thank you that's
the amount of involvement for me one of
the editors is a Chast her oh my God I'm
obsessed cuz they always do like
whenever there's like a documentary
about pop culture they always do like a
Roundup of it in the news and it's like
yeah we should be in there yeah know
it's very sweet oh my gonna watch it
yeah um so at like the 25 minute Mark I
watch the whole
thing okay well you would have maybe
watched it anyway cuz like that's your
beat you like the beat was there any new
information about trailer that you
didn't know no no it was very basic it's
for like an older person who is like
what's going on with this Taylor Swift
got it okay so that is what happened
between tree
and do last night but then do responded
but then do responded and honestly when
I saw that tree like woke up and decided
to drag d by her hair like I was quaking
for do okay so that's what I was just
about to say like do you think D is
[__] her [__] pants because what
I think maybe some people do realize and
some don't like do is just one gal it's
not like a whole media company it's just
one girly who does all this work she's
very nice
like I would die right so I would have
thought that D Dum mua was [__]
herself like oh my God she gonna like
crawl into a hole for a little bit let
this blow over but then she responded
and her response she had some big brass
balls cuz she's doubling down and I have
more respect for that and I actually
think that's a better strategy than her
kind of like cowering into herself well
if she does cower and just be like I'm
sorry no one will believe anything she
ever says right but so it's much easier
to do that than it is to stand your
ground especially because like p and
Trauma oh okay I'm sorry yeah but it but
it is easy to St on your ground
anonymously but she's not insiders know
who she is like tree knows who she is
yes yes yes um also she's like come out
there's like she has has she like there
was an article I think that she
contribut there's like an article about
do and who do is and I I feel like she
vulture did a piece like we figured it
out oh it was it figured it out not like
d sit down not Do's coming out no it
wasn't a d out debutant B okay well this
is what D said in response she said well
I make 0 from lying can publicists say
the same also to relate something that
is in reference to something that
happened years ago to quote pain and
Trauma after what just happened seems
like a poor choice of words either way I
apologize to Taylor after what just
happened what happened the deadline
article I'm reading thinks that it's
about the fan in Rio I of course you
know think it's about October seventh
but yeah that's what I was thinking too
just where my yeah pain and Trauma like
right right oh oh oh oh oh but I do
think it's about the
fan after to what just yeah probably the
fan no that response is Like a Knife I
don't think this was wise it was it's so
out of character not wise for tree yeah
it's so out of character to respond to
anything but I don't know does Juma
still have that sort of choke hold on
the culture please sound off in the
comments cuz for me personally it
doesn't it doesn't penetrate anymore
yeah and there was a time though that it
did I don't think it was like Duma
posted this and everybody was like oh my
God Taylor's been married because
apparently duma's been saying this for a
while yes she has I think that maybe you
know Kylie Kelce is a big Duma fan and
she saw this and she was like Travis do
you know that Taylor has been married
and then everything got blown up I don't
think Kylie Kelsey or really anyone in
the Kelsey Clan is reading tabloids I
honestly I think if any anybody was
reading Jima Kylie Kelce would be the
last person yeah maybe Mama Kelce loves
Jima like there she's on her Cruise
she's
scrolling Mama Kelsey's tapping through
her IG stories by the way so there's a
celebrity cruise going on right now that
like a lot of celebs are on Mama Kelsey
oh my God that's the one that Ben was
supposed to be on that's the one that
Ben was supposed to leave for a few days
ago but he stayed home with Theo and
canceled his trip I told him to go I'm
actually so glad he didn't I could not
be doing this by myself but but Ben was
supposed to be there I'm literally I'm
literally Madison beer right now you
know I was supposed to be in the
video I am glad that Ben is with you and
with d d the first but he should be on a
cruise with Mama Kelce like that's what
the world needs no Donna and eaah like a
lethal
combination that's upsetting I
know but there's no worthier cause to
stay home for like I don't have there
was nothing else to be done yeah of
course but like it sucks for Celebrity
Cruises because it's a Celebrity Cruise
Line and they could have gotten Ben
offer celebrity and that just sucks for
them yeah but they do have Mama Kelsey
and she was listening to Taylor Swift in
the background of her story everyone I
saw freaking out she so cute while she
was tapping through dumo by the way so
Taylor and Andrea were she's supposed to
be with Donna and the
Kel's in Kansas City for that game but
then the shows in Rio got postponed so
her schedule got [__] up I do feel
like the I don't think the families have
met yet and I do think they'll probably
spend the holidays together in Kansas
City somewhere they're saying she's like
staying in Kansas City for a while I
don't know if holiday house is going to
happen it's going to happen yeah she's
in Kansas City even though she did leave
to go to London last night to go to
Beyonce's premiere for Renaissance movie
and Beyonce had a Premiere in the states
and Taylor wasn't there cuz she had a
show but I was like damn Beyonce showed
up for you and you're not showing up for
Beyonce I was like damn that's kind of
crazy no she got her she made it work
she got her ass on a plane I'm sure
she's back in Kansas City already she
just like flew in for this event um so
she is like home based is Kansas City
and Travis like a few hours after Taylor
landed in Kansas City Travis was seen at
Trader Joe's in the local like Kansas
City town and he was buying ice cream
for Taylor and like people were freaking
how do you know it's for Taylor I just
feel like Travis is an athlete he
probably doesn't need ice cream no I
feel like he's like eats a million
calories a day but what's more classic
it's like babe I'm hungry can you go get
me ice cream like it's for Taylor
I think it's for both of them I think we
I think we all like ice cream I think
they both do probably like ice cream
sharing a
spoon so cute one spoon what flavor did
anyone get the flavor no apparently like
people in Kansas City were so respectful
like there were videos of him walking
around the store totally normally not
one person went up to him he was lovely
everyone was well behaved so I'm sure
that's why he loves his town so much
they really respect him even at this
level like they're leaving him alone
yeah that's hysterical okay so that is
what went down between tree Taylor and d
d MOA and I just want to go on the
record saying like this was an
uncharacteristic move of tree and Taylor
and I actually don't think it was the
right move and one more question do you
think they had a
ceremony
no I do not think they would have
responded so publicly which they never
do if there was even a glimmer of truth
to it cuz that's an insane thing to do I
think it's one of those things where a
ceremony can be interpreted into a lot
of different things and in Doom they're
talking about the same event and in
trees mind this was not a marriage of
any kind and in du's mind it's like oh
this was a ceremony in the elk of a
wedding elk yeah wedding elk yeah it's
possible oh I have to add that to the
list of words that we're never going to
use properly again or say properly cuz
it's like ilk no no but it's ilk but I'm
saying the wrong word like elk is an
animal oh yeah so you're saying it wrong
but you're using it
right I guess it both yeah okay just
going to add that great there was
another one you we can't be held back by
like social constructs and words and
their meanings because we are the elk of
dreamers you know we are also language
is ever evolving and why not why can't
we put our spin on it it's so true
language is for me at least it's
interpretive you know what it's giving
the Tower of Babel the Tower of Babel it
always comes back to the Tower of Babel
so true the Tower of Babel is my Roman
Empire like really one of them that I'm
constantly like cross referencing in my
head like Tower of Babel what a lesson
what a lesson what El you want to know
what the tower the moral of the story of
Tower of Babel is shut the [__] up no
it's about girl bossing too close to the
Sun H literally M it's
beautiful are you ready for our next
story yeah Kelly Clarkson's ex Brandon
Blackstock must pay her over $2.6
million for unlawfully procured business
deals obsessed okay if there was like we
used to do this in our family like
weenie of the week oh my God have we
ever told the toasters about weenie of
the week it was one of the most hurtful
things like ever because we would do
just like the sisters and we wouldn't do
it every week no but we when ever like
someone would remember we would do we of
the week and we would like we'd all
nominate one other person we couldn't
nominate ourselves obiously a sister not
a person in the world like it was
between the four of us and we had to
nominate one of the sisters as the
weenie of the week and cite what they
did that was weenie-ish and the way like
you and Olivia only ever chose me and
Margot you and Olivia never won formed
an alliance it was always me or Margot
and it was just like it was stupid cuz
it wasn't fair no I mean it doesn't seem
like like the most fair and generous of
spirit sort of game no I hated weenie of
the week it was always me well I just
want to say like Brandon Blackstock is
the weenie of the
year I forgot why we were talking about
weenie of the week Brendan Blackstock is
the weenie of the week every week like
this man just takes L after L after L
and it's all because of his previous
action so it's like it's just
no it's actually really beautiful to to
be watching someone face the
consequences of their actions over and
over again like this is a bad person you
know who stole and
manipulated of the woman he loved the
mother of his children like how rotten
can you be and it's like of course
mother of children woman you love like
you should never betray her but also
like it's Kelly Clarkson America's
sweetheart like pure goodness no and I
know that the judge prided over this
case like he was calling and voting for
Kelly Clarkson like
that's That's How Deep The Kelly Stan
Hood runs like but it's actually so true
like cuz when American Idol was on like
even if you watch it religiously or you
just like pass were a living person you
knew you had you were impacted by Kelly
Clarkson you don't think the judge was
calling for Justin guini no was anyone I
think that when Kelly cried during peace
by piece the judge cried during peace by
piece
1,000% and now we're seeing the judge I
just think it's it's going to be
impossible for Brandon Blackstone to get
a fair trial in this country because of
Kelly's impact well you should think
about who you're harming then well you
should just also just think about
harming in general harming in general
it's a good lesson Bron I love this
here's the story Brandon Blackstock
helped orchestrate several business
deals for his ex-wife Kelly Clarkson
while serving as her manager but he
wasn't supposed to a California Labor
Commissioner has ruled earlier this
month Clarkson scored a victory in her
latest legal battle against Blackstock
according to documents of obtained by
people he's been ordered to pay hers
$2.6 million for overstepping in his
managerial role and unlawfully procuring
deals that should have been handled by a
talent agent his legal team has filed to
appeal the
ruling I hate this man with every fiber
of my being and I just feel like in the
last like year or two Kelly's had a
couple of really big legal wins because
she didn't do anything wrong and the
laws on her side and the J you know the
judicial system is slow but the wheels
of Justice are turning in Kelly's favor
so this is just another one you know she
won that child support thing she won the
prenup he tried to have the prenup void
like he's just been a dick at every turn
and he took her house yeah the ranch and
he was ordered to give it back to see
him losing brings me great joy yeah the
wheels of Justice turned slowly and of
course you know not to bring gender into
it but to see a man like a greedy little
[__] try and leech off a successful
woman who's you know a mother an
entrepreneur a com a touring uh singer a
daytime host like to see an unemployed
slob try and bleed her out you know suck
her dry it makes me sick the me men
should be ashamed it's it's terrible
yeah no especially I feel like there are
a lot of men who like when they're
married to a woman they try and like you
know manage and take ADV and make
themselves and ride the
coattails and in to some degree that's
like you know that's their job and
that's lawful and they're just you know
why should someone else have this job if
I could do it but the fact that he was
also being like a crook a crook about it
yeah like why don't you just like ride
her coattails lawfully yeah no why don't
you just like be normal and be like a
stay-at-home husband like I'm sure Kelly
would have been happy to make the
fortune and you just not do anything but
he's also he's a music manager like have
other clients don't [__] where you eat
oh by the way he did have other clients
that's what's so greedy about this he
was Blake Shelton's manager and when
Kelly and him decided to get divorced
Blake Shelton took you know Kelly's side
and dropped him as his manager but up
until that point like he had a career of
his own yeah so why you got to go and
steal
too why you got to be so mean no I hope
he like I want him to lose every penny
to his name like you're going to be a
criminal cool Kelly's coming for you
yeah Kelly's coming for you are you
ready for our next story what number is
this three yes some Disney tea from back
in the
day I don't know if you've seen it but
we always love Disney tea from back in
the day so Kim rhods who played okay I
know I actually right before we started
watching this I was watching a clip of
her on Christy Carlson Romano's podcast
exactly Kim Rose who played the mom on
Sweet Life and Zach and Cody she played
the the singing mom who's the mother to
the twins um The Cabaret she was kind of
like Cabaret with a countess before she
was kind of like a crazy Queen no I was
obsessed with her of course you were cuz
she was living her dream singing she she
sings on a cruise ship like it takes her
everywhere she's sing at a luxury hotel
no and she like her passion afforded her
children like amazing opportunity she
was an incredible mom she was a single
mom who works two jobs who loves her
kids and never stops a gentle hand and
the Heart of a fighter she's literally a
Survivor yeah so she choked up as she
recalled an incident on Christy Carlson
Romano's vulnerable podcast where she
claimed that an executive allegedly
bodyshamed Dylan Sprout in front of the
show's cast and crew she said the
executive had screamed at craft services
that there should be no more junk food
until Dylan looked like his twin brother
Cole and who also starred on the Disney
Channel sitcom she defended the then
teenager at the time and [__] lit
into the network bigwig whom she refused
to name I was like you do not have the
right to say that to a child you do not
have the right to be writing for
children if that is your attitude never
again do speak like that never she also
recalled a time where the boys were uh I
think it was Dylan he was instructed to
make a fat joke about her on the show
and he wouldn't say it he just kept
skipping over it she told listeners she
said it was like in the middle of a
chunk of dialogue so he kept skipping
this laugh line finally we get in front
of the studio audience and he skips it
and the executive producer screams cut
Dylan say the line and he goes I would
never disrespect any woman that way let
alone this woman you write you write
something funny and I'll say it oh okay
slay with the with the y- old um that's
like kind of one of those quotes that
it's like I don't know that a 9-year-old
said or he was probably 13 like I will
never disrespect any woman that why let
alone this woman but I do believe that
like he he said some iteration of that
and he a child's version of it and that
he refused to say the joke and refused
to disrespect her but there was a lot of
mutual standing up for one another yeah
that story about C Services when I saw
the clip like that was wild cuz I do
remember a time of course where the
twins looked different but they were you
know pubescent growing that's what
happens and honestly I think for a lot
of people it was how they started
telling Dylan and Cole apart and I think
it actually in the end contributed to a
lot of their individuality like for real
yeah I do cuz I think as a twin they
were so similar looking like the hair
the clothes everything so I think it
establish them as like two different
people at first and I don't think it was
a bad thing
and to know I feel like so there's like
this conversation being had now on
social media especially on Tik Tok where
there's a couple dis former Disney stars
who are grown now whose entire brand is
what basically Christy Carlson Romano is
doing having a podcast inviting others
on and talking about their show so the
three kids from Ned's Declassified
School Survival Guide have their own
show that's like you know being talked
about anaise Vander Poole who is Chelsea
from that so raven has her own Christy
Carlson Romano of course the Wizards of
Waverly Place um and people on Tik Tok
are like dragging them cuz like it's
annoy oing and it's all they talk about
and all their Tik toks everything is
just about this one job that they had um
but I don't feel that way about this
particular conversation because I I
watched a lot of this podcast and Kim
rhods talks also about how like she's
very famous people recognize her she
doesn't have a career she says she's you
know virtually un bookable she doesn't
have health insurance like I actually
did think it was an interesting
conversation um and kimrad seems like a
really really nice lady yeah no that
sort of conversation does bother me I
feel like it's the opposite that bothers
us when people are known from their one
show and they don't talk about it and
they're like think they're better than
that but see as like a a child star
there's really no way to win because if
you don't talk about it we are like oh
my God it's annoying talk about the
thing and if you talk about it they're
like oh my God will you ever stop
talking about it like what how really
how are you supposed to exist post post
that well that's like anything it'll
never make people happy so just talk
about it to the degree in which you're
comfortable yeah I feel like someone who
does a good job of that is Josh peek
yeah because he obviously has the this
thing Drake and joshh that's so huge but
he really did a good job of like he
talks about it if you ask him about it
but he doesn't make it his personality
and he'll he'll engage with like the
funny hug me brother type of things but
he also has a life and a family that he
talks about and fatherhood and he was in
the Vlog Squad temporarily like he has
other things that people I feel like
when I just said Josh peek your
immediate thought wasn't Drake and Josh
right no it's good guys it's good guys
and Oppenheimer yeah so I think he's
kind of a a perfect example of how to
tow the line but I imagine it's very
difficult yeah you know who I feel like
actually does a pretty good job
considering it's hard who Hillary
Duff yes but Hillary Duff is different
because she went on to be in things that
were just as big as yeah Lizzie MaGuire
yeah that's true so it's it's a
difficult spot to be in yeah well okay
ticktockers if you don't like it don't
listen to it yeah and I I thought that
Christy Carlson actually did a really
good job with this interview cuz Kim
rhods was like dropping truth bombs
after truth bombs and I thought that
story about craft Services was just wild
and it's so something I could see
happening oh of course the people who
run those kid shows are disgusting
disgusting it's like this is just I feel
like a tip of the iceberg I mean and the
way that they make kids feel the way
that they talk to kids like
that's you know doesn't even go below
the surface of some of the stuff that
happens right but I always felt like
those types of stories were really
reserved for the other networks like
especially Nickelodeon I think
Nickelodeon and if you read Janette
mcc's book there's so much in there
about Nickelodeon I don't really know of
a lot of traumatizing moments or stories
that I can think of from Disney I think
Disney was very like exploitative you
know you think of like Miley and Selena
and Demi like they're all like
traumatized from Disney not necessarily
in the way that some of the Nickelodeon
kids might have been traumatized and I
think we're all talking about like down
Schneider yeah um and the allegations
against him so I don't I hadn't heard
anything about that like at Disney but I
think it was you know as far as kids go
like a toxic work environment and
they're not
Tre they're not treating kids with kid
gloves yeah not treating kids as kids
yeah like they couldn't get you know
they have to do their schooling and they
have to do their show and they're the
the centerpiece of the show there's so
much pressure on them and their kids
going through puberty and their emotions
are heightened and like no one's there
caring for them they're just like get
back to work yeah yeah yeah know it's
very like a sweat shop like 247 so I
don't think they look back on it fondly
but I think maybe an adult like Kim RH
in certain like when you're an adult and
you're on this like great show and you
have a lead role but it's not all on you
like it's a more of a palatable work
environment except for when they're like
fat shaming everyone right right right
she just seemed like a really like she
had a great hat on her shoulders in the
interview she like looks really similar
she just has a big arm tattoo um she
seemed like like a sweet lady she
reminded me a lot of her character like
a very maternal energy very calm
peaceful I really like her we knew Sweet
Life of Zack and Cody
reboot do we yeah with her and the boys
everyone I want everyone ter Mr Mosby
London in terms of that showd there's
there's actually a lot of actors from
that show who went on to have usually
it's just like the star but we have
Dylan and Cole Brenda Song Ashley
Tisdale there's quite a few people who
made it out even Mr Mosby does he act
and other stuff yeah I'm pretty sure I'm
pretty sure he was um conin a
manslaughter in like 2014 or something
what yeah Phil Lewis is his name right
yeah yeah okay never mind am I right
about manslaughter why did Phil Lewis
get
arrested he was involved in a horrendous
tragedy oh okay never mind yeah
yikes
yeah are you ready for our next story is
it our next story that's brought to you
by L'Oreal
it is this episode of the toast is
brought to you by the new L'Oreal Paris
bright reveal dark spot serum and
broadspectrum sf50 daily lotion dark
spots game over so if you want to
visibly fade all different types of dark
spots you have to check out these
products from L'Oreal dark spots a lot
of us notice them mostly in the summer
but they are year round you have to be
protecting your skin with SPF and then
if you do get dark spots you can treat
them with these L'Oreal products so the
L'Oreal dark spot serum it's the bright
revealed 12% dark spot serum visibly
Fades all type of dark spot up to 40%
and after 12 weeks up to 40% less
visible on post acne marks 43% less
visible dark spots and 49% more even
tone in one week it starts fading even
the most stubborn dark spots and after
two weeks your skin will look clearer
skin texture will look more refined and
smooth and it's made for all skin tones
it's suitable for sensitive skin the
formula is validated by dermatologist
then they also have the bright reveal
SPF daily UV lotion you should use this
before you get dark spots it'll help
protect your skin 100% of dark spots are
all intensified by the sun this product
is lightweight and non- greasy it's a
sunscreen that has an invisible texture
it Blends seamlessly with all skin tones
and it primes really well with makeup we
should all be wearing SPF under our
makeup a lot of them can leave like a
white cast and just leave your skin
feeling like icky and clogged this SPF
bright reveal 50 daily lotion from
L'Oreal is fabulous discover the new
bright reveal dark spot Duo visit Target
online and in store to buy yours today
and those two products are the L'Oreal
bright reveal 12% dark spot serum and
the bright reveal spf50 daily UV lotion
today's episode is also brought to you
by State Farm the state firm personal
price plan helps you create an
affordable price just for you the plan
is all about being personal to you and
your needs that means you're going to
get the coverage you want a policy that
helps cover what's important to you and
an affordable price just for you because
after all life is just better when you
can personalize your experiences so
think about it like this from your go-to
coffee order to your favorite pair of
sweatpants we know that you love to
personalize your entire day just like we
do now I don't want to get into you know
I don't want to fight this morning on
this beautiful Friday right okay so
let's just leave it let's leave it at
this like we are different yeah like you
like a warm bowl for lunch MH and you
like a breakfast taco for
breakfast and that's just you know a
very small indicator of how different we
are when it comes to insurance we have
such different needs I mean you have not
one but two cars you have dependence you
live in a different state you're a
homeowner I don't have much to my name
but I still require Insurance you know
I'm a renter and that's what State Farm
gets it and that's what the State Farm
price personal price plan is all about
they believe that insurance should work
the same way your plan your coverage
your selections can and should all be
personalized by
you like a good neighbor State Farm is
there call or go to statefarm.com today
opt prices vary by state option selected
by customer availability and eligibility
may vary you want to you want to try it
close us out with a little jingle like a
good neighbor State Farm is there that
was pretty good like a good neighbor
State Farm is there prices vary by state
options selected by customer
availability and and eligibility may
vary thank you Claudia you're welcome
okay our next story a little Clarity on
one of the breakups from this past week
Dave poroy reveals the reason behind his
split with Silvana okay so Dave pnoi was
on his podcast BFF's pod just one week
after she revealed they're no longer
together and this is what he said
because a lot of people were like
wondering why they broke up there was
the rockel rumor which obviously wasn't
true I'm sorry if people believe the
rockel rumor I don't think people do but
people are still waiting we need to all
like use critical thinking sometimes
like the way rumors just get spread so
fast like people are being stupid yeah
like you're being dumb use your brain he
didn't hook up with Raquel quote we were
dating for 3 years and I guess you get
to a point where you think maybe there's
a difference in what somebody wants and
what the other person wants and without
going into too much detail I just didn't
think I could give sylvana kind of what
she deserves she's so beautiful she's
funny she's smart she's all these things
he admitted that it was probably a me
issue and he doesn't think that he is
the guy she's looking for and is going
to be able to provide her with what she
needs down the road he said he felt like
he was quote stealing sylvan's youth but
didn't elaborate on whether or not had
to do with the brunette Beauty wanting
to settle down that's that's probably
what it was it's giving like of Scott
dick Shep and Taylor like I don't want
to be married I don't want to have kids
and like a a young girl is like okay
with that up until a certain point no
and a young girl every girl thinks like
yeah he says that but I'm different yeah
and like we have a great relationship
for 3 years even the way he's talking
about her on the podcast she was his
best friend he misses her so much he's
very concerned and like wants good
things for her it literally is exactly
Shep and Taylor if you watch Southern
Charm like they were such a great couple
Shep was so happy Taylor loved him so
much and like was waiting for him to get
it but there are men who just never will
settle down you can be the perfect
person inside and out and do everything
and like be there read willing and able
and they just don't want that I don't
understand it but that's just them no
same so like I I wasn't particularly
surprised by this breakup I think
there's really only so long you can be
in a relationship without that doesn't
progress before things get Troublesome
and that's young woman when you have
like you know desires for what you want
your life to look like I mean if you're
someone who if you're a young girl who
never wants to get married and never
wants to have kids like you should call
Dave pornoy it's so true but I think
even sometimes young girls go into like
a relationship like that oh I don't care
about like marriag and kids but then you
grow up within the relationship and
those things start to matter for you and
then the relationship can't work but I
just like can't understand I feel this
way when I'm watching Southern Charm I
felt this way about Scott D with Sophia
Richie like and he's always dating young
girls cuz a girl at 21 yet she doesn't
want to get married yet but when she's
25 she's like hey what about that
marriage I don't understand these men
who are so so against like marriage and
and kids the thing is same because if
you're going to be in a three-year
monogamous relationship like that's
marriage getting married changes nothing
from being in a committed relationship
making the jump to marriage quite
literally your life doesn't change at
all I understand people being very
hesitant to have kids like that's your
whole life being flipped on a dime but
the fear of commitment while being in a
committed relationship makes no sense to
me yeah yeah people are very like
freaked out about marriage you're living
with someone you're monogamous you do
everything together you hang out with
her family she hangs out with your
family how is that different than just
being married I think the kids is a big
piece of it I think like for everyone
it's like okay for well we're we getting
married then we're having kids therefore
we cannot get married I feel like the
men feel that way and also the women
feel that way like I don't want to
necessarily be married to someone that I
can't have kids with if I want to have
kids yes no no no for
sure so that answers that and it makes
sense I just like why why no but also
Dave pory a lot of people forget was
married right a million years ago no no
that would be crazy yeah I don't know
what happened to men like this like
Shep yeah and I mean Scott obviously has
kids but does it ever
change like no I mean do they become
like that guy in their 60s yeah who's
like finally ready George
Clooney yeah he dragged that Stacy
Keebler around town for years I don't
know he felt a little different he was
always kind of dating like age
appropriate women like yes yes but they
never ever ever got serious past like
just being in a committed relationship
sh never engage never marry never kids
yeah then I don't know if it's the woman
like was a m different but you know he
dated beautiful successful smart women
his whole life yeah they were all
wonderful wives could be wonderful wives
and mothers and they all went on to be
wonderful wives and mothers yeah it's
not about the
woman it's it's like that thing from um
Sex in the City it's really the perfect
um met for it's every every man is a cab
yeah and if you hail one when his light
is on it's just TI it's not you yeah
it's timing but I don't know how like
people like this change or when or why
they would maybe they get older and they
start to like have an existential crisis
and they're like let me try something
different but whenever I like I to me
like Shep and Dave are the same person
and I just don't see them ever changing
no yeah shepa is also just very stubborn
yeah I don't know Dave but I in this
situation like if you were watching
Southern Charm right now like Taylor and
Shep were the perfect couple like she
made so so happy he literally like CED
like they shared a dog and uh Shep it's
Shep's dog Craig little Craig and like
when Shep sees Taylor with the dog who
she had to leave when they broke up like
he cries over like missing Taylor and
their dog and their little family and
it's like why not marry the girl you
love her so much you love her so much
even like when Paige was she went down
to South Carolina she was like Shep
loves Taylor so much like what if you
just stayed with her and got married no
I can't with people who refuse to be
happy like No And also what's crazy is
like shef parents are still together so
like what he grew up in a loving home
like what's the problem right like back
to Matthew Perry's book he's never been
able to have any sort of Happiness when
it comes to relationships he was
abandoned as a child that carried him
through his entire life every year for
his birthday he would wish for his
parents to get back together his parents
[__] hated each other like hate they
maybe have been in the same room three
times in the last 15 years like hate and
that is so prevalent his mother really
never gave him attention she worked so
hard she was a single mom all he ever
wanted was attention he has a fear of
Abandonment like he just used to leave
good relationships before that person
left him like there's a psychological
reason like he when he spell it out he
been burned he has you know past pain he
doesn't believe in it momy issues he
can't he's never seen it if you can't
see it you can't achieve it yeah I
believe Dave Porto's parents are also
still married what right so like what is
this I don't I don't know but like girls
you can't change them yeah if you're in
one of these situations like thinking
you're going to be different like I love
you I'm sure you're an amazing person
but you're not different it's not about
you it's just about something and
sometimes it never the flip never the
switch never flips for a man sometimes
it does it has nothing to do with the
girl but sometimes they don't do not be
wasting your time in relationships like
this like for real it will you will
drive yourself mad and you'll think it's
about you when it's not yeah well at
least he said it's a me problem right
and at least he was kind enough to
realize he's stealing her Youth and like
she should get on with it and I have to
imagine he was pretty open with her from
the beginning like you don't get a
threeyear relationship without telling
someone you don't want to get married
yeah they broke up like the Sunday
before Thanksgiving they were supposed
to spend Thanksgiving together they just
like got into a conversation about the
future he said it wasn't the first
conversation like this but it was the
last one yikes yeah it was a little like
out of left field considering it's the
holidays the timing like wasn't great I
think their parents were both in town
like ready to spend but that's it that's
how the cookie crumbled speaking of
cookies are you ready for our fifth and
final story I am I love this story
Subway and announces foot long cookies
and is giving them out for free on
Monday so again if there's a free snack
the toast is going to let you know where
to find it and this one is a special one
because it's a foot long cookie but it's
also Subway and the reason why I wanted
to talk about this story is we rail on
subway all the time we don't eat their
sandwiches the stores smell like [__]
but their chocolate chip cookies are
amazing yeah and I they must be in like
a special you know vacuum sealed Vault
because they don't smell like the rest
of the store no it's true it's true so
the fact that they're doing something
different with their cookies and you
know they're known for their foot long
so it's like a funny you know it's like
literally it looks like a piece of bread
it's a foot long cookie imagine getting
two of those and putting a little bit of
ice cream between them should have SC
you should go treat yourself 100% on
Monday though when it's free I love this
sort of on genuity in marketing and
baking and I just I give this tens tens
tens across the board the subchain
announc that it will add 12-in cookies
to menus Nationwide in early 2024 but
before adding the foot long dessert
across the country Subway is handing out
the new dessert for free at select
locations next week so listen up Monday
December 4th is National cookie day and
fans can visit a restaurant in Chicago
Dallas Miami and New York City to snag
one free foot long cookie with any
purchase of any foot long sub okay you
have to buy a sub so it's not like
totally free tury you have to buy a sub
so it's not totally free oh uh get b a
tuna sandwich doesn't he love their
tuna or he hates it he it's not real
tuna he used to eat it a lot as a kid
and then it came out a few years ago
that there's actually not even a 1%
trace of tuna fish in their tuna salad
got it but wait this just reminded me of
something okay I saw something on Tik
Tok over the weekend it was just like
the the biggest chain restaurants in the
United States in terms of uh locations
okay I want you to guess McDonald's is
number one yes number
two sub boy yes well just cuz we're
talking about it and you like don't you
find that seem surprised strange
I I can't say that I do I'm not an
expert on the matter because I'm I don't
keep up with Subway like if there's a
Subway if I pass a Subway it does I
don't register it if I pass a McDonald's
golden
arches number three Taco
Bell it's like a different category
you're not you're have to think a little
bigger like
chains a drink chain sorry bucks yes for
you're never going to guess it found
shocking
no uh Red Robin KFC oh that's not that
crazy
six can you just tell me Burger King
seven Pizza Hut eight
dominoes nine Duncan 10 Crispy Cream
Taco Bell is 11 Crispy Cream to me
they're like so Random diamond and the
like
a needle and a hay stack you can never
find one right but this is just about
location so I do think it's regional
like to certain areas no so there are
people who have Crispy Cream of Plenty
the way that we have Duncan in New York
they have Krispies yes where can we move
to they have Chris over 10,000 locations
to put in perspective McDonald's which
is number one has 40,000 and Subway has
37,000 Starbucks has 36,000 that's
because McDonald's is not a burger
business it's a real estate company
right and we learned that from what was
that if you haven't seen the founder add
that to your list of family movies
it's also I want to just talk about
something for a brief second and it's
about Spotify wrapped okay are you
starting to see like more and more
inconsistent information coming out of
Spotify wrapped I'm not really looking
for inconsistency I'm not looking for it
either but like everybody's listening
sounds brings them to Provo
Utah yeah I heard about that mine was
too what was your listening sound I
didn't see that statistic I didn't even
know what people were talking about I
must have tapped through it they had
like some random statistics you listen
most similarly to Provo Utah like a
bunch of people like what's going on in
Provo that's where those schools are I
was going to say what's going on in
Provo is illegal like those that's where
those ESG schools are that where Paris
Hilton went provoc Canyon yeah they're
like listen music there
right I guess what they're saying is you
have the same sort of Music taste as an
angsty teen EG GS not ESG I have the
same music tastes in ND anyways I'm just
seeing like and people's they're not
making sense I feel like there was some
plant
planting going on on the lists well
sptify you4 hours to respond beest to
bring it all the way to the top was
Taylor even the number one most streamed
artist or did they want in on the Taylor
I do think she was I really do like I
think it's fairly I think it's
believable because like she's
everybody's listening to her her she had
like three album nobody had Taylor Swift
in her top five was like what I never
listened to Taylor Swift I know I'm just
saying Spotify rap doesn't seem as data
driven as it once did that's all I'm
saying oh wow that's a huge accusation
to her all it's a huge I just feel like
there were a couple things that were
planted in there not necessarily Taylor
but then it makes you question the
validity of
Taylor and if there's one lie it makes
you question what else could be a lie
right if if there it's rotten at its
core if yeah if there's a piece of rot
you have to peel away is the whole thing
rotten and I've never felt like like
that about Spotify wrapped you haven't
you're always always lauding it for I'm
such aamp of Spotify wrapped you really
are but we have to be asking the hard
questions or else we're not doing our
jobs so drill now we can go embark on
the weekend have our lunch let's do it I
hope everybody has an amazing
restorative and relaxing weekend thank
you so much for listening to the toast
the millennial Morning Show where we
deliver the fast stories you need to
know everybody the Friday on YouTube so
you're watching us on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as podcast any every podcast
and wly talented we are have an amazing
day happy weekend happy Friday we love
you dearly and we'll see you tomorrow
love you
bye